we have some good vibes for you courtesy  of john stamos the full house star  teamed up with tick-tock singer jax to  pull off an epic surprise for her mom  yeah this all came together after jax  shared a cover of her singing the full  house theme song on tick tock following  the passing of john's late co-star bob  saget two months after that video was  posted she joined forces with john to  surprise her mom with her celebrity  crush bye everyone that's awesome  surprising my mom with her celebrity  crush  stanley  our video  everybody meet my mom  she's been married to my dad since 93  but she did always warn him the man of  her dreams was john stamos so we made a  video we hope he sees  i promise i love your dad  [Applause]  okay would you leave him in a heartbeat  for john stamos just admit it okay fine  but don't tell him that  [Music]  i'll tell him what  my mom is uncle jesse's girl  [Music]  you're beautiful  you're married  no